I don't know if anyone here is refuting
the science does anyone here disagree
that the more calories you consume and
you don't exercise yeah we all agree are
they sugar pop said he disagree yeah
okay
you can't put calories on a leaf you
can't put calories on spinach you can't
do this you just see it goes from the
ground that's when I think with all this
calorie counting and stuff like that how
do you actually calorie count a carrot
because each carrot is different and
when you add also did you know calories
you know food calories when they say
you're on the label like whatever
calories it is did you know each person
consumed in their body when they consume
food the calories change and it's
different for each person